so this recent paper has got quite a lot
of attention and it includes a lot of
words you hear a lot on this channel
it's analytics and lifespan so i thought
i would read the paper
plus i was also lucky to hear toru
minamino present this data at the
senescence conference last week
which i unfortunately had to watch from
the comfort of my home instead of osaka
so hello and welcome to the shiki
science show where in this video i will
break down the results and discuss
whether we have a faxing now for aging
so xenolytics then
these commonly refer to drugs that
selectively kill senescent cells
cells that accumulate in the body with
age and through their inflammatory
phenotype are thought to also contribute
to aging
however i think now's analytics are more
generally referred to as any strategy
that can selectively kill these
senescent cells and leave your healthy
happy cells happy and healthy
only last week did i inform you on a
recently discovered cinelytic
procyonidin c1 found in grape seed
extracts so another drug-based approach
but another approach that i want to
remind you of was this antibody drug
conjugate
here if you remember they targeted
senescent cells by having antibodies
recognize membrane proteins expressed on
the membranes of senescent cells
and these antibodies are conjugated to a
cytotoxic drug
such that when they recognize the
membrane protein and are subsequently
uptaken by the senescent cell they cause
the senescent cell to die
now whilst the membrane marker used in
this study may not be the best choice
if more selective proteins can be chosen
it will help to reduce negative and
unknown impacts on healthy cells
which would still be targeted by the use
of synalytic small molecules like
pro-cyanide and c1
so this now brings us on to the recent
publication
sonolytic vaccination improves normal
and pathological age-related phenotypes
and increases lifespan in prodroid mice
so how does this strategy work
well firstly they chose a different
membrane target
here they selected gpnmb a glycoprotein
that is upregulated in vascular cells in
patients and mice with atherosclerosis
and the expression of gpnb
is correlated with other senescence
markers so the authors first developed
antibodies that could recognize the
protein gpnb and then they could give
these to the mice as a vaccine as the
antibodies can activate the immune cells
to then kill cells that express the
protein gp and mb so similarly to how
vaccines that recognize antigens
expressed on cells that come from
ferreters or bacteria that your immune
system can use to kill infected cells
it's just this time the marker is gpnb
which is expressed on some senescent
cells
so how did they test their vaccine well
first they fed mice are high fat diet
from four weeks of age which increases
the abundance of gp and mb which is
expressed along with these other
senescence markers then the mice were
vaccinated against gpnb at eight weeks
of age and analyzed eight weeks later
and while it seemed to work it reduced
the signal of gpnb along with the
reduction of sa beta gal which is used
to mark senescent cells here you can see
in adipose tissue and to also improve
the metabolic profile shown here in the
glucose and insulin tolerance test
so you might be thinking well how does
this compare to other synalytics well
you're in luck because the authors also
thought that
again feeding rice are high-fat diets
instead of giving them the vaccine at
eight weeks they gave mice satanism and
quercetin for five consecutive days
at eight weeks and also again at 12
weeks of age and they did the same thing
with another synolitic no fetal arcs
in all cases they saw a reduction in
tennessean staining and visceral adipose
tissue at 16 weeks of age
however it was only in the vaccinated
mice that these beneficial effects were
maintained at 24 weeks of age
so the key difference seems to be in
permanency once you've got immunized
with the senolitic vaccine the body
continues to recognize the expression of
the synolytic marker gpnb
but due to these stronger and more
permanent impacts on the organism i
suspect it will take longer to see
something like a vaccine developed for
humans as is potentially the risk for
autoimmune diseases recognizing a
protein that our body makes but there is
also the argument that you could just
keep giving the mice this hit-and-run
strategy with this analytics
at more time points than was tested in
the study
so what about longevity well to
investigate the vaccine on lifespan they
then vaccinated a progeria mouse model
so here the mice have a mutation such
that they age faster and compared with
control mice vaccinated at 10 weeks of
age showed a better survival rate albeit
it was more significant in the male mice
than the female mice
so all in all i think this was an
interesting study though i don't think
i'd get too excited just yet
there are many other ways to induce
senescence and many other tissues that
weren't examined in this study
there doesn't appear to be much talk
about translating this to humans yet
either which i'm not really surprised
about
i think it's more of a proof of
principle but it demonstrates the
variety of strategies that are being
developed so that's pretty cool
so anyway i hope you've learned
something in this quite brief video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening
you